[Musique]
alors quand on est un adolescent normal
on passe beaucoup de temps dans le cadre
de son lit on se repose on est un petit
peu comme un chat et j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour les chats qui savent
très bien se reposer mais moi quand
j'étais adolescent en fait je voyais les
copains qui partaient en vacances et qui
disaient c'est super on va se reposer
mais moi de mon côté je savais que
j'allais partir en stage de natation
j'avais nager deux fois par jour et que
j'allais m'endormir avec la peau qui
tire à force de rester dans l'eau
chlorée
alors ça m'a donné des succès
j'ai été à 14 ans déjà mes premiers
championnats de français Niort c'était
pas très loin d'ici à Vittel et j'en
garde un très bon souvenir et au bout de
la ligne le fil en aiguille je me suis
retrouvé dans les 10 meilleurs mondiaux
donc sur 100 mètres brasse aux Jeux
Olympiques
et puis quelque part d'aller chercher
tout le temps la limite de se dire tiens
jusqu'où est-ce que je peux aller dans
toutes ces histoires que j'entreprends
et bien c'est devenu une habitude alors
à l'école je voulais être en tête de
classe et puis je me suis retrouvé avec
un doctorat en mathématiques appliquée
sur un sujet très sexy en physique
déplacement pour la propulsion ionique
des satellites
tout de suite ça vous donne envie d'en
faire une j'espère
et
ensuite quand j'ai arrêté l'Aïkido le
pardon la natation justement je me suis
mis à l'Aïkido que j'ai fait assez
sérieusement pendant 15 ans et je me
suis dit art martial japonais forcément
j'ai sauté sur l'occasion d'aller
travailler au Japon pendant deux ans
d'apprendre la langue et de converser en
japonais avec des gens qui pour certains
ressembler un petit peu à Maître Yoda
alors quelque part de repousser tout le
temps ses limites je me suis dit ça
c'est intéressant et rétrospectivement
je me suis rendu compte aussi que
j'avais tenté de briller dans un cadre
qui avait été établi par d'autres
et les psychologues connaissent ça bien
ils disent que c'est naturel en fait que
dans nos jeunes années on se construit
dans un cadre qui a été fabriqué par nos
générations qui nous ont précédés et
puis ça donne lieu à des satisfactions
des joies alors par exemple sur cette
photo c'était le jour où j'ai été
champion de France pour la première fois
sur 100 m brasse et là je me régale
c'est pas du tout de la douleur c'est
quelque chose qui ressemble à
l'excitation de Noël quand on ouvre les
cadeaux et après toutes ces heures et
ces années d'entraînement mais en fait
on découvre l'étendue de son aptitude ce
jour-là on ne savait pas avant de le
faire
et puis quand on regarde quand même on a
une face du cadre qui est coloré riante
les podiums les sourires
et puis il y a l'autre côté du cadre qui
est moins rigolo parfois on n'est pas
sûr d'avoir envie d'aller à
l'entraînement parfois on a des doutes
et puis parfois on est fatigué et on se
demande mais pourquoi je fais tout ça
et on creuse un petit peu et on se rend
compte on se rend compte pardon que
peut-être je suis en train d'essayer de
combler un manque
alors la bonne nouvelle c'est que ça
nous donne une certaine envie de
dépasser un petit peu tout le temps de
chercher mais on se retrouve un petit
peu à chercher chercher chercher on
apprend à aller dans plein de direction
et par exemple vous connaissez ce
problème ou on essaye de connecter enfin
de passer par les 9 points
avec 4 segments sans jamais lever son
crayon et puis il y a une solution
classique qui est d'autant plus amusante
que la personne qui cherchait c'était
limiter à un cadre qui n'existe pas donc
en fait elle avait fabriqué un cadre
elle s'était mise des limites et ça
rendait le problème impossible et là
tout d'un coup hop c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant et quand on se rend compte
ici que il y a encore d'autres solutions
où on se rend compte que justement on
n'avait pas besoin de passer par le
milieu des points
on se pose la question qu'est-ce qui se
passe dans notre cerveau qui fait que on
s'est mis des limites
alors qu'il n'y en avait pas
alors il y a une bonne nouvelle c'est
que on est une espèce qui est capable
d'inventer des limites là où il n'y en a
pas mais on est aussi une espèce qui est
capable d'imiter nos congénères quand on
voit que eux ils ont décidé qu'il n'y
avait pas de limite et on fait ça il
trouve une solution élégante et on peut
s'en inspirer exemple
ce cycliste a découvert qu'il allait
plus vite dans cette position et rien
dans le règlement ne disait que pour
faire du vélo il fallait avoir les pieds
sur les pédales
alors il fallait y penser on est
d'accord mais dans les descentes en fait
ça lui donne un avantage il allait plus
vite que c'est collègues et puis quand
il double quelqu'un mais quelle bonne
idée
et voilà une idée
qui fait des petits
et donc notre cerveau est capable de se
dire un mais tiens je peux profiter de
l'expérience des uns et des autres et il
y a des cadres comme ça qui
s'agrandissent pour aller chercher
peut-être des choses que je ne
connaissais pas et que je cherche encore
peut-être pour combler un mot qu'on se
dit tiens on cherche
dans un autre genre vous avez peut-être
joué dans une cage à poule maintenant
c'est interdit mais
[Musique]
mais on n'est pas tous comme ça et d'une
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que
votre cerveau géomètre il est toujours
là il est toujours précieux il est
toujours curieux et on va explorer les
dimensions spatiales ouh là là
alors
voici un objet qui représente donc une
dimension de se promener sur une ligne
et dès qu'on met des limites ici et bien
on est contraint de se promener
simplement sur cette partie là on est
limité par une simple un petit point une
petite barre un petit segment on peut
pas aller au-delà mais
et là attention
sponsorisé par les magasins de bricolage
quand on le plonge cet objet dans un
espace à deux dimensions un plan voilà
tout d'un coup on n'est plus limité on
peut se promener tout autour et
maintenant
les limites sont les bords de ce cadre à
deux dimensions et là vous me voyez
venir votre cerveau géomètre
est en pleine ébullition on se dit bah
maintenant ce cadre qui me limitait à
deux dimensions si je le plonge dans
l'espace à trois dimensions et bien je
peux me cogner ou je peux faire le tour
je peux traverser le cadre je peux
m'appuyer sur le cadre et donc le cadre
devient en quelque sorte un ami un
soutien
donc on se dit tiens voilà qui est
intéressant mon cerveau géomètre se dit
mais si je suis un moment limité par
quelque chose peut-être que je vais
rajouter une dimension je vais chercher
dans une autre dimension et puis je vais
continuer ma recherche beaucoup plus
enfin disons une recherche beaucoup plus
vaste
alors notre société nous donne beaucoup
d'escaliers on peut partir dans plein de
direction on peut décider d'être plus
riche on peut décider d'être célèbre on
peut décider de faire du sport de la
musique etc etc on peut décider d'avoir
des likes sur Tik Tok
et puis on tourne on monte et on descend
les escaliers et au bout d'un moment
parfois on s'arrête et puis on se
demande pourquoi je fais tout ça j'ai
toujours un manque il y a quelque chose
ce manque je n'arrive pas à le combler
et pourtant je suis allé loin pour
chercher
et vous connaissez sans doute ses
comptes ou le héros est allé très loin
chercher un trésor et puis il revient
dans son village pour se rendre compte
que le trésor était dans le village d'où
il est parti il n'avait jamais cessé
d'être là alors c'était important qu'il
fasse le périple mais c'était important
qu'il revienne chez lui
et alors en ce qui me concerne le plus
beau moment de ma carrière de nageur
si je devais n'en garder qu'un c'est pas
sur un podium c'était pendant un
entraînement très anodin en quelque
sorte je ne l'ai pas vu venir et puis
pendant une série de jambes en palme à
un moment je reviens en dos et là à un
moment de grâce la lumière était belle
quelque chose était très agréable dans
le fait de glisser dans l'eau de sentir
et d'écouter le clapotis de l'eau près
de mon bonnet de bain et à ce moment là
en fait j'étais
en contact avec le monde et c'était un
contact qui était délicieux
et donc ça c'est un plaisir qui
ressemble à celui après un long voyage
ce plaisir qu'on a quand on rentre chez
soi dans son fauteuil préféré on
s'assoit on fait une pause je sens je
suis je goûte et donc cette dimension
peut-être au lieu d'aller loin chercher
quelque chose peut-être on peut explorer
une autre dimension qui est la dimension
du sensible
et je vais vous inviter pendant quelques
instants à faire une petite exploration
ensemble sensorielle pour faire un pas
dans cette direction et pour faire un
pas dans cette direction et bien je vais
questionner un petit peu votre relation
avec le monde votre rencontre avec le
monde vous rencontrez le monde par le
regard vous voyez on a une belle salle
les gens autour de vous sont très
sympathiques et puis vous rencontrez le
monde aussi par le toucher et peut-être
que vous vous en apercevez mais vous
rencontrez le monde par le toucher à
travers vos fesses
et oui votre point de contact avec le
monde toute une partie de la journée
c'est à travers vos fesses est-ce que
c'est de l'amour ou pas c'est une autre
question mais en tout cas on va s'amuser
un petit peu avec ça et je vais vous
inviter à prendre enfin à avec votre
main droite en fait à la glisser entre
votre fesse droite et votre fauteuil
vous ne saviez pas que vous alliez faire
ça ce soir ça commence fort
et puis en plus une fois que vous avez
fait ça si on vous demande qu'est-ce que
vous avez fait ce soir
vous pourrez dire on a touché nos fesses
mais n'oubliez pas s'il vous plaît
rajoutez tout de suite chacun les
siennes on veut pas de problème alors
maintenant que vous avez une main comme
ça sous la fesse droite et bien vous
sentez de l'os
et c'est le bas de votre bassin alors
des gens vont dire non je suis pas sûr
etc mais si vous sentez de l'os
vous avez de l'os et cet OS en fait donc
c'est une partie du bassin qui s'appelle
l'iskyon et bien vous pouvez décider de
basculer votre bassin un petit peu vers
l'avant et vers l'arrière et vous le
sentez rouler sur votre main
vous pouvez décider aussi de presser de
peser un petit peu plus sur votre côté
droit ou de peser un petit peu moins sur
votre côté droit et votre main et votre
fauteuil vous donne des informations sur
ce qui se passe
et pour finir vous pouvez décider aussi
de faire glisser un petit peu votre
isquillon droit donc un petit peu vers
l'avant un petit peu vers l'arrière et
vous sentez quelque chose sur vos doigts
et maintenant petit tour de magie si
vous enlevez votre main
probablement le fauteuil semble avoir
changé de forme il y a un côté qui est
plus profond alors que le fauteuil n'a
pas changé alors si ça marche modérément
vous pourrez réessayer chez vous mais en
tout cas cette expérience en fait est là
pour montrer quelque chose c'est que
votre perception du monde en fait c'est
un petit peu le monde et c'est un petit
peu vous ce que vous avez fait ce que
vous y apportez ce que vous espérez etc
et c'est ça qui va former l'image que
vous avez du monde c'est une rencontre
alors je vous invite en fait à faire un
petit peu comme notre héros vous faites
un long périple vous avez glané beaucoup
de choses et vous avez appris beaucoup
de choses pendant ce périple mais quand
vous empruntez la dimension du sensible
vous rentrez chez vous et vous trouvez
des trésors autour de vous dans votre
maison et puis c'est trésors vous aurez
probablement envie de les partager de
les échanger avec le monde qui vous
entoure et dans cet espace où vous
échangez vous partagez et bien le manque
n'existe pas
alors je ne sais pas si c'est un trésor
mais c'est ce que je voulais partager
avec vous ce soir merci
[Applaudissements]